since the launch of its belton road
initiative
china has been seeking to unlock
opportunities for collaborating with its
former
cold war comrade but despite
an urgent need to plug its 100 billion
infrastructure gap
growing nationalistic sentiments prevent
vietnam
from fully embracing china's new silk
road
[Music]
and over in laos joint projects ranging
from malls
to a mega railway are helping shape the
country
into asean's next investment hotspot
but with the threat of a debt trap
rising will its increasing reliance on
china
ultimately become boon or bane for
landlocked laos
one country is seeking to mature its
economy another
is on the cusp of something big both
share a neighbor
who is promising support in exchange for
a slice of their economic pie
can the new silk road truly create a
win-win situation
for vietnam laos and china
[Music]
this is laokai a province in vietnam's
northwest
it's famous for its rice terraces and
lush green mountains
which are among the tallest in the
region
[Music]
but i'm not here just for the scenery
my journey to explore china's new silk
road has brought me to the capital of
this picturesque province
which shares a border with hoko an
autonomous county in china's yunnan
province
i've been greeted with wet weather upon
arriving here
but for the people of laokai province
their rainy days
are now far behind them thanks to china
and this is why over the past few years
lauka has been at the forefront of
vietnam's trade with china
the border between lao kai and hoko
which means river mouth in mandarin
is located right at the convergence
between vietnam's red river
and china's nangxi river
[Music]
and every day vast numbers of goods are
transported over these rivers
via three different border crossings
by rail and by road
but those without the luxury of wheels
have a different border crossing
experience
one that's a little more hectic i mean
it
is literally a race across the china and
it happens
every day
look at them go
carrying whatever they can in their
baskets and trolleys
sometimes a little too much these
farmers and vendors from the nearby
vietnamese hillsides
are all competing to be the first to
reach the local hoco markets
where spots to sell their goods are not
fixed but grabbed
based on a first-come first-served basis
it's a dash because those who arrive
late to the chinese markets
probably won't be able to sell all their
goods and they'll be making that return
trip back
with full baskets and empty wallets and
that
is a walk of shame no one wants to make
45 year old vegetable seller xian takes
part in this mad rush
every morning while the border gate
opens at 7 00 am
every day his day begins three hours
earlier
at the laukai wholesale market
[Music]
here he and his wife spend more than an
hour picking the freshest produce
which they will later carry across the
hoco
but i wonder if the payoff from his
tedious daily routine
is really worth it
[Music]
has your standard of living improved
since doing trade with china
[Music]
selling vegetables in china compared to
what he would make
selling them locally he bought a
motorcycle just for the job
but before he can sell anything he along
with hundreds of others
have to first cross the border the
immigration clearance is a fuss-free
affair
made all the more pleasant by a very
welcoming vibe
the easy crossing is telling of how
close these two countries have become
[Music]
imports and exports via laucai totaled
1.6 billion us dollars
just in the first half of 2018
and during those same six months the
export of agricultural
and seafood products from lau kai to
china raked in more than 300 million
dollars in revenue for the city
[Music]
but while the people of lao kai have
certainly profited from cushy relations
with china in the present
you do wonder if their past ever gets in
the way
of their furthering this newfound
[Music]
friendship
i'm in the mountains overlooking laokai
province
in 1979 this valley was a battleground
the site of one of the fiercest fights
between vietnamese and chinese soldiers
in the month-long sino-vietnamese war
the border war was triggered by
vietnam's invasion
cambodia which was then under the rule
of the china-backed khmer rouge
in 17 days of bloody fighting thousands
of vietnamese died
[Music]
now nearly 40 years on i'm wondering if
the folks from this very community
caught in the epicenter of that conflict
have managed to move on
31 year old ty runs the most popular
restaurant in lao kai
he was born eight years after the
conflict but vaguely recalls stories his
parents told him
about that dark episode in vietnam's
[Music]
history
foreign today
tai and his family have not only moved
on from the war
they welcome the chinese who spend as
much as a hundred and twenty thousand us
dollars
every month at his restaurant nearly
half of their customers
are chinese nationals who regularly
cross the border
for the fresh seafood laokai is famous
for
you interact with chinese visitors at
your restaurant quite a lot
what impression do you have of the
chinese
[Music]
but outside laokai the mood may be a
little less conciliatory
[Music]
what happened in 1979 remains fresh in
the minds of vietnamese across the
country
[Music]
some groups have even resorted to using
1979
as a linchpin to stir up tensions
surrounding the two countries
territorial disputes in the south china
sea
most recently in june 2018 plans to
build three new special economic zones
and a bill proposing new lease terms for
foreign firms
sparked fresh protests
under new laws foreign investors can now
lease land
in industrial parks like these for up to
99 years
so longer than the terms before which
was 70 years
and that is wearing many vietnamese who
fear the government's relations with
china
are a little too cozy and worse that
they might have already given the mighty
chinese
a little too much game in their own
economy
economist dr voe tritan feels that the
worries and fears on the ground
are still a little too premature because
the draft laws would have to go through
many rounds of debates and deliberations
before anyone decides to pass them
you need to go through the rigorous
procedure and at the end you need your
decision by the prime minister many guy
or dimension we think about right
revision right
in terms of incentive for the business
for the investment
so uh right now a lot of debt
in vietnam right now whether we need to
that kind of
economic patient zone right because we
are not already very open
whatever the outcome of the bill it's
unlikely that chinese investors will be
perturbed by the recent developments
for many chinese companies vietnam
offers cheaper labor
and a relatively young population with
workers below the age of 35
dominating the assembly lines
all this coupled with access to the
broader asean market
is what attracted vina solar a leading
producer in solar panels
to set up its manufacturing operations
here
by utilizing cutting-edge robotic
technology to produce high-quality solar
panels
vena is seeking to promote the use of
chinese solar technology
among the vietnamese community
the majority of people in vietnam and
across southeast asia
can't really afford to install solar
panels in their homes
so who are your main customers then
women
there's been a rise in anti-chinese
sentiment in vietnam recently
and in the past protesters have attacked
factories and companies
how concerned are you about this shinto
from creating jobs to cross-border trade
the benefits of collaborating with the
chinese are being appreciated
by locals across the country
but a vast majority of the population
have mixed feelings about china's new
silk road plan
and are instead pushing for stronger
ties
with vietnam's former enemy
[Music]
i'm in vietnam one of asean's most
dynamic economies
and one of two communist countries in
the southeast asian region
and vietnam's embrace of its communist
identity
is hard to miss
socialist posters like this one can be
found in public spaces across the
country
the national flag bears a variation of
the iconic star
a universally recognized symbol of
communism
there's even a park dedicated to
vladimir lenin in the heart
of hanoi
[Music]
you'd expect china and vietnam's shared
communist ideologies
to smooth out the rough patches they've
had in the past like the 1979 border war
and the ongoing territorial disputes in
the south china sea
maybe not because both countries might
still be reconciling their checkered
history
and that's despite being comrades in
arms during vietnam's
most famous war
ironically many vietnamese still appear
to be more forgiving towards the
americans
whom they spent 20 years fighting than
the chinese who invaded the country
in 1979.
in fact a recent survey found that 84
of vietnamese viewed the united states
favorably
compared to 10 who expressed positive
attitudes towards china
but the reality is in recent years
it has been the chinese not the
americans that have been helping vietnam
develop some of its most critical
infrastructure
the vietnamese government continues to
be caught in a tough balancing act
while it recognizes the people's
attitudes towards china
it also needs to raise more than a
hundred billion dollars worth of
investment
to meet the country's infrastructure
needs and china's extensive belt and
road initiative
offers many opportunities for vietnam to
fill this wide infrastructure gap
a case in point is the katlin hadong
urban railway line in hanoi
for which china provided more than 300
million dollars
in loans it also supplied the manpower
and technology
that was used in the railways
construction
one man on road can have a
positive contribution to infrastructure
development
in vietnam so far uh you can observe the
tariff reduction very significantly even
we have
in the recent many fbi free trade areas
so a tariff is no more problem so
how you can facilitate detroit
investment and business so connectivity
infrastructure development is important
in principle vietnam has already
committed to participating in china's
belt and road initiative
chinese president xi jinping's visit to
vietnam in november 2017
saw the signing of an mou in which both
china
and vietnam pledged to implement the
belton road initiative
but the question on many observers minds
is whether the recent mou
would lead to any further substantial
collaborations
so far not any project come from that
initiative of eoi
or not like many other other countries
they already have some disbursement from
iib i think that because of two reasons
number one vietnam in the process of
development and we change
we are man the infrastructure
development strategy
since the launch of the one belt one
road plan china has repeatedly
emphasized that the initiative is not
just about investing in
infrastructure it also hopes to use the
new silk road to promote cultural
exchanges between the chinese
and communities around the world
in line with this goal beijing
co-sponsored the construction
of this state-of-the-art building
the china-vietnam friendship palace was
officially opened by chinese president
xi jinping himself
in november 2017.
this massive mural is what greets you
when you enter the palace
and it depicts a very vibrant cultural
exchange between the two countries
china and vietnam and it showcases
the various ethnic groups cultural
performances
and it really encapsulates what both
governments
seek to achieve with this venue
the 35 million building is decked out
with the most modern equipment and
facilities
it has everything you'd need to hold
meetings dialogues
and parties between the two sides
but since it opened about a year ago
there hasn't been any of that happening
just yet
don tuan fong is the vice president of
the vietnam union of friendship
organizations
the institution which runs the place
at the moment the palace is not under
phone operation
as some of
the technical checkups
adjustments have to be made uh
but activities like country events
performances exhibitions
language classes traditional medicine
receiving visitors
from vietnam and china those kind of
activities will happen
at a time when there might be certain
strong feelings towards china in the
region
how important is it for organizations
like you
to kind of create
a a bridge between
let's say vietnam and china the attitude
of the
of vietnam is to
work together to address issues
and with disputes
over the islands that belong to vietnam
we are determined to
[Music]
continue working with other countries
especially china to address
according to international laws
and by peaceful means
through diplomatic channels and
we think peace is key to
development and prosperity
while we wait for the china-vietnam
friendship palace to officially open
locals elsewhere in hanoi have already
taken it upon themselves
to promote chinese cultural activities
in their community
[Music]
take hai for example he's a former
national athlete
who was sent by the vietnamese
government to china to learn wushu
when he returned he set up this tai chi
club in hanoi
now he's imparting those same values and
philosophies he learned about the art
form
to his students
[Music]
do you think that cultural activities
like tai chi
may be a solution towards building
bridges between the two countries
[Music]
m
[Music]
the key to mastering tai chi is finding
your balance
ah thank you and that's something
vietnam's government
is struggling to do as it seeks new
opportunities
for collaborating with china while at
the same time
being careful that it doesn't alienate
itself from its public
amidst a growing protest culture
[Music]
but stories like that of highs do offer
some hope
it's an example of meaningful
people-to-people exchanges
which is a key pillar of the belt and
road initiative
[Music]
progress on that front is already in
high gear across the border in laos
where chinese and laotians now
collaborate in many industries
from construction to film production
the chinese might be winning low hearts
and mines in the process
but can their money help laos where it
matters most
to fulfill the landlocked country's
ambitions to be asean's
next investment hotspot
[Music]
i'm on the final leg of my journey along
china's new silk road in indochina
and today my travels have brought me to
vientiane
the capital of laos but before i begin
my journey
exploring china's growing footprint in
the country i'm going to take a slight
detour
to check out a prominent bntn icon
[Music]
it's the first stop for any tourist
coming into the city
and the most important national monument
in town
the patusai
laos arc the triumph as tour guides call
it seems to be
iconic and ironic
[Music]
fashioned after the one in paris the
patusai is a tribute to lao soldiers who
bravely fought
and died during the country's struggle
for independence
against the french
[Music]
french and indo-chinese influences
inspire its design
and the cement that was used to build it
all was donated by the united states
the americans thought it would be used
to build an airport
lao oceans would have an ark instead
the city's older residents call this a
vertical runway
just nearby another monument has a less
complicated context
i'm not only interested in fatsusai but
also what's next to it
here's a water fountain donated by the
chinese government
a symbol of chinese friendship right in
the heart of laotian history
a sign of the deep ties that the two
countries share
[Music]
nearly 15 years since the fountain's
installation
the relationship between beijing and its
southern neighbor
is stronger than ever because of what's
happening
elsewhere in the country
there's a constant flow of chinese money
into laos
and that's slowly turning this
developing country into an
investment hub china has invested in
everything
from hospitals satellite internet and
television
to shopping malls
[Applause]
[Music]
and when it comes to malls vientiane
center
built two years ago is currently the
newest and biggest in the country
it's five hectares of anything a
vientiane city slicker might ever need
including a singaporean style food court
dominated
by chinese food stalls
this mall is actually pretty small
compared to malls in
other capital cities across asean like
bangkok for example
however i must say that this mall looks
pretty
sleek and modern and as the first fully
air-conditioned
retail and entertainment hub in the city
it fills a critical void
in lao society especially for its youth
that's if they can afford any of this
the average laotian earns just a little
more than 200 us dollars a month
what this new mall is really selling is
a new middle-class lifestyle
that's very aspirational and very
exciting
and i wonder if those aspirations are
within the reach of most locals
i'm meeting miao chang-woo he's the
general manager
of north gnongchan development the
mall's parent company
as the manager of this mall what has
your observation been
um do you find that the typical laotian
customer or guest to the mall are they
able to afford
the majority of products that you have
for sale here
yes i think the majority of our products
they affordable for them uh like for
instance
for one noodle one lunch you can go like
20
000 gib in u.s is around two and a half
dollars it's affordable and the for the
close the price
is around a hundred thousand keep so
in dollar it's gonna be like 15
okay 15 to 20 dollars
so it's not expensive in your opinion
would you
describe the majority of your customers
as mainly being
maybe middle class uh i think
yes middle class because before the more
opening
for the people who want to get middle
class
products there's no place
for them to sharpen that so they're
going to cross the border to thailand
[Music]
shopping wasn't the only attraction that
drew laotians to thai malls
there was also this other fix
laotians do love their movies and with
the opening of this cinema on the top
floor of vientiane center
many have been spared the hassle of
crossing the border to catch the latest
hollywood flicks
this five-hall cineplex boasts the most
modern theater facilities
in the country and it's on par with any
modern cinema
in the region this is easily the most
popular place within the mall
especially among the youth
i'm told that in addition to local and
hollywood films
the cinema also screens chinese movies
which have become
very popular among the laotians
but laotians are not just watching on
the big screen they're also watching in
the comfort of their homes
and it's not just movies but chinese tv
dramas as well
which are a big hit in laos
they're such a staple among lao
households that an
entire industry has emerged dedicated to
converting them
for audiences here
has one of the most famous voices in
laos
he's been the go-to dubbing artist for
english movies for more than 40 years
now
but these days salyon and his audio
engineer
are getting much more work coming from
chinese content
there's much more demand for them thanks
to tv platforms like lausa
a chinese-run satellite tv service based
in vientiane
[Music]
why do you think there's been such a
strong demand for
chinese films and tv dramas among
lao audiences
you might have audiences who are
learning korean
to follow the korean dramas or they will
watch the series in the original
language let's say like chinese
and then have the subtitles in their own
language
why do you think that laotians
want to watch chinese film and tv dramas
dubbed in in lao uh
honking
from malls movies to manufacturing
[Music]
china has pumped billions of dollars
into laos over the past
five years making it the largest foreign
investor
into the country and much of this
investment
is concentrated in a multi-billion
dollar mega railway
that will link laos major cities to
china's yunnan province
but will this mammoth project plunge the
country
into a debt trap
[Music]
as a landlocked largely mountainous
country with many in the population
living in poverty laos has for years
been perched high on the united nations
list of least developed countries
[Music]
in an attempt to graduate from this list
the lao government has sought
billions of dollars in aid and
infrastructure investment
from china this has helped laos develop
critical infrastructure
and places it on track to become asean's
next
investment hotspot
i visit a belton road project that seeks
to bring laos
closer to realizing this goal
through the belton road initiative china
has poured record amounts of capital
into their less wealthy southern
neighbor one of their more prominent
projects
is this one the cycetta development zone
which was jointly set up by the
vientiane municipal government
and the yunnan construction and
investment holding group
it's mostly a vast vacant plot now with
just over 40 factories
but once construction is complete this
thousand hectare plot
will be more than your usual industrial
park
there are already plans to build schools
hospitals
apartments shopping centers and even
tourist attractions
ah so what is this here yes
is chairman of the laos china joint
investment company
the consortium responsible for
developing this zone
he saw the strategic value in setting up
a special development
it would take another five years for the
saisetta development zone to take shape
and while both the lao and chinese
governments hope to draw on the success
of the zone
to elevate laos profile as an investment
hub
they are faced with one critical
challenge
laos own geography
with its majestic mountains and green
valleys through which flows the mighty
mekong river
laos offers some of the most
breathtaking views in southeast asia
but these natural wonders are also its
greatest curse
the terrain makes travel across the
country difficult
and that has long deterred investors
i visit the site of a six billion dollar
chinese project
which promises to help laos solve this
perennial problem
[Music]
the key to the success of the seiseta
development zone
is transforming laos from a land locked
to a land link country
and here's how china is helping laos
achieve this
as you can see construction is already
underway in luang prabang
for a 414 kilometer railway line linking
china
to mainland southeast asia when
completed
the railway has the potential to help
laos boost
transshipment income by plugging the
country into the broader belton road
[Music]
network
[Music]
this is just one of dozens of tunnels
that are being built to allow trains to
cut through laos
numerous mountains and they won't just
be passing through mountains
but across rivers as well
here in luang prabang a massive bridge
is being constructed
over the mekong river which will
eventually be linked to the tunnels
while i can certainly see how laos
stands to benefit from all this
connectivity
i can't help but wonder about the impact
of all this construction
on this heritage town
[Music]
oh it's about ebola
is a staunch supporter of the project
because of the hundreds of jobs it has
created for the local community
including himself he works for the
chinese railway construction company
as the captain of this barge
the barge transports trucks and
construction supplies
across the river every 30 minutes
along with creating jobs chittapan
service also benefits his fellow
villagers
who travel on the barge for free
[Music]
while the mega railway is being
celebrated by many in the local
community
it has also attracted skepticism
the project is funded almost entirely by
loans from china
and with the country's total public debt
currently at 70 percent of its gdp
laos is in critical danger of being set
up
for a debt trap with china
but tanongsen ganlia who works in the
laos chamber of commerce
feels that the costs are justified in
the name of progress
you know you look into the long term you
know development
so we have moved from this
landlocked okay to landline initiatives
and i think that
in in as a way although it's a big
investment
but i think is a way that can help i
don't
think that it's just the only way but it
can be one of the
options that can help so i think uh
connectivity is very important
and that's the reason maybe the
government has decided to go although
it's very uh
a big project and it will cause a lot of
public debt
in neighboring vang vieng faith in the
mega railway project
is equally strong there's a train stop
planned for this riverside town
and that's raised optimism among the
businesses here
ever since construction began many
foreign investors
have also set up shops and restaurants
in anticipation
of receiving more visitors and more
business once the railway starts
running
tang a chinese entrepreneur was quick to
jump on the bandwagon
he runs a tour agency specializing in
outdoor activities
such as kayaking and buggy rides
already his business attracts close to 4
000 tourists a month
he believes this is nothing compared to
the number of visitors who will flock
here
once the belt and road infrastructure
projects are completed
[Music]
as the saying goes when in rome do as
the romans do so i conclude my six
country journey by exploring vang vieng
the same way tong's customers do
[Music]
all right time to rock and roll
[Music]
[Music]
this journey has certainly given me a
lot to reflect on
i've seen firsthand how chinese
investment has improved the standards of
living
for many communities throughout the
region
but i've also seen cases of how these
success stories
have come at a price for the locals
there are still challenges that states
within asean
need to address eventually with china
despite how much chinese investment
is being celebrated the new silk road
offers many opportunities to collaborate
and i would like to see this spirit of
cooperation continue to inspire
solutions
for overcoming the existing challenges
it's only then that china's growing
footprint into asean
will not be met with fear but a sense of
[Music]
hope
[Music]
you